the jurgen experience the letdown i  think the caleb just handed the verdict  to the gym oh my god crank it up crank  it up oh my god the johnny depp verdict  live this is insane  she's so crazy i feel like look i don't  want her to have to pay him money i  really don't because i think that that  lady's broken and psychologically she's  so damaged she's so crazy and i think  the real punishment is that it's been  exposed to the world how insane she is  yeah like she's insane and she's a liar  and it's like  that lady needs to go to the jungle and  do some ayahuasca and get connected to  the mother and then come back and  apologize as opposed to his right it's  now i feel like i'm watching someone get  beat up and her dean should step in yeah  curb team where are you now  yamasaki yamasa  no it was the other one steve mazzagotti  that one yeah the guy will let some  fights go  sorry i'm sorry  you